good morning Millennials welcome back to
the morning toast
it is a nice enough Wednesday here in
New York City how you Darrin Claudia
what up Joe stairs happy home doner a
favorite day here at the morning toast
I'm not feeling really humpy yet maybe
it's just because I just changed my
duvet cover and I have underboob sweat
maybe later in the day I'll start to
feel like humping someone and I'll talk
to Theo but for now I don't know what
hump days just aren't the same you know
in quarantine no they're definitely not
the same for me now that I'm not
spending them with zo it's so upsetting
that's what I'm trying to say he's the
king of hummed a he is and he just he
wanted me to relate to you because he's
like busy and and to all the toasters
that you know I know that today is not
the day we thought it was gonna be this
is like our seventh hump day in a row
not being together as a community and
Theo just wanted everyone to know that
he is here for us he's offering free
guidance councelor sessions via
telehealth so if anybody's looking for
an appointment with Theo you can contact
his assistant directly and he's more
than happy to help
I heard he's also singing with some of
his medical friends a video of them
singing imagine is going around just to
help inspire people as Theo's in-house
PR rep I can confirm what those rumors
are 100% not true and yo hasn't heard of
this video he does not know anything
about this video and this is actually
the first we're hearing of it he's it's
narrative he wishes to be excluded from
one he never asked to be a part of it
very much so thank you for your time
there Sam right okay Wow I'm so glad
that we cleared that up on Theo's behalf
yes I have really nothing new to tell
everyone except for that I watched a
whole other season of RuPaul's Drag Race
and I'm not sure if anyone wants to hear
about it but I have a lot of thoughts on
season six because the first episode
started and I thought it was a joke
because these girls were just
unfortunately nothing of the sort and I
thought it was like a joke
but then it ended up not being now I
started season 7 which is violet chachki
Trixie Mattel and like every girl on the
first date could be a winner so it's
weird how the seasons like are either
consisting of girls where nothing of the
sort or or something of the sort
interesting well he sits a fair playing
field yeah it's really just really
enhanced my life in such a fabulous way
and I'm so glad that I have this and I
find myself I know I keep saying this
but I'm really like being like so rou
you know when I talk I'm just so
theatrical and I keep saying like guess
work work so I'm just really turning
into RuPaul don't mind me love that
um I'm turning into the Unabomber
because I started watching last night
manhunt Unabomber because a lot of
people suggested that after Waco I might
like it and while the show isn't done as
well as Waco was done and the way that
it's formatted it's kind of annoying
it's another story another major story
that i weirdly did not know about i've
heard of the term Unabomber but like i
thought it was someone who had a bomb in
his underwear like i had no clue what it
actually was and i realize it's because
all of these things happen all of these
things happened when i was alive but
like too young to be participating it
was like in the 90s so i was probably 5
but then you know i was too old to have
learned about it in my textbooks so this
chapter of American history in like the
90s is just lost on me so I have so much
catching up to do and if anybody has any
other suggestions of shows similar to
Waco or manhunt that I would like please
recommend them I'm just loving a
historical miniseries that is my new
favorite thing like a limited series
about something that's true and a well
done story like Chernobyl you know I
made snitch watch Chernobyl and if you
haven't watch turnable yet you
absolutely must so that no one of the
journey I'm going down I haven't
finished a Unabomber yet but they got
the guy and it's about to get good so
payoff you're leaving today it really
disrupted my TV schedule but I had to go
back to input to know to watch okay well
Vanderpump brawls and I wish I could say
that it was worth it like it wasn't even
worth it no it was so weird for me to be
like really learning so much about
American history and then be like oh my
god a sir softball game yeah it was at
best a week episode and just now that
I'm choosing my content in terms of like
I have so much more time and really
investing in my content and now
finding things that are really like
enhancing my life just to go back to
cable sometimes is it's really like a
challenge
ya know it was it was challenging last
night but I think Tuesday nights are
always the hardest cuz we go back to
chemo for one show where's her the rest
of the week like we go back for Beverly
Hills Kardashians Real Housewives of New
York like it becomes more worth it
so also glass nice episode did have its
moment so I'm excited to talk about it
it wasn't all just like Sur softball
game nonsense no no it wasn't but it was
an hour for like four minutes of [ __ ]
that I wanted to say yeah well you know
it was good for me cuz I needs to switch
gears in my mind because I couldn't have
fallen asleep after just like they just
getting to the cabin because I was
already like you know just too much
going on in my head and if you haven't
watched Waco yet make sure you watch it
everyone's watching Waco now it's all
anyone's talking about I have to believe
that it just got to Netflix and that's
why we're all watching it um and it's
it's just so good
it shouldn't I actually think that you
should watch it I'm so like in another
place in my life like maybe down the
road I could get to a headspace where I
would watch it but I'm just in this this
dread place where I literally cannot
watch anything else but it's the
craziest story that you've never heard
no I knew about it so what do you know
what happens do you know what happens I
do okay well I don't want to spoil it
because it's better when watching him
know if I can clue what's gonna happen
because then you're yes it is to the
calm we would like to do today we have
dear toasters which is our advice Eggman
if you ever want to write it in you can
always email us dear toasters at
gmail.com we're gonna read recap better
pump rules and then of course deliver
the fast five stories so I think that it
mm-hmm anytime I think that it's time to
jump right in because again like this is
three days in a row now where we have
some real stories for you guys so we
love it you it is time for the past five
stories that you need to know before you
wake up and take a bite out of your
morning toast
and that's true Jackie but I just I have
one thing to say and it's really been
bothering me and I would like to get it
off my chest
today's episode is brought to you by
cherry the latest
honest uninfluenced real beauty reviews
cherry is a new Beauty attribute for
beauty skin care and wellness
enthusiasts to freely share their
sites opinions and personal stories in
an honest and thoughtful forum Chery
features everything you need to know
about products and practices from every
corner of the beauty skincare and
wellness universe in an honest
straightforward and unbiased way cherry
is devoted to showcasing product reviews
created entirely by people with honest
uninfluenced opinions this means that
users will always get the truth about
products and treatments whether
consumers liked them or not and they
just launched $100,000 future Beauty
fund to support the LA Beauty community
they are committing a hundred thousand
dollars to local beauty service business
businesses and professionals in Los
Angeles impacted by the effects of koban
1910 beauty service businesses nominated
and voted for by you will receive $5,000
from cherry additionally 50 Beauty
professionals will be paid to create
original content on the cherry app
sharing the talent expertise and best
advice for the beauty community
community download that in the Apple App
Store or visit cherry calm CH ER ie calm
today to nominate and vote for your
favorite beauty service businesses like
hair salons nail shops facial spots
anything that has been impacted by koban
19 winners will receive $5,000 from
cherry to support the future of their
business
that's cherry comm CH ER IE or you can
download it from the Apple App Store
nice okay first story gigi hadid and
Zayn Malik are having a baby
gigi hadid is pregnant and the dad-to-be
is her on-again off-again boyfriend Zayn
Malik TMZ has learned this is a TMZ
exclusive family sources for the couple
tell them that Gigi is 20 weeks along
it's unclear if they know the sex of the
baby yet but both of their families are
very excited
the supermodel shared some celebratory
photos with the former One Direction
singer this past weekend but they
weren't baby related they were birthday
pictures her sister Bella was also in
the pictures and she said that she had
the sweetest day celebrating her 25th
birthday with her Quarantine family so
they're all in the queue together in
Pennsylvania I think it's yo longest
farm there it's a farm come and buy like
I'm so here for it and a pregnancy vibe
and I'm [ __ ] shook
I mean I'm shook because at first I was
like there's no way that this is true so
I was thinking of I was gonna you know
embark on a battle as to find the truth
like what's actually going on but then
after being so widely reported not as
rumor but as fact I think we pretty much
confirmed
it is true so now that I know that I am
just like wrapping my mind around this
whole thing I think it's so crazy like
obviously it's wonderful a baby's always
a blessing but it's just so crazy it's
so unexpected they're so on and off um
GG's out like the height of her modeling
career like you wouldn't expect her just
to get pregnant but she did and it's
it's crazy I know I'm actually really
excited for them because there they are
so on and off again but I feel like this
sort of thing makes them on forever and
I ship east to like I think their OTP
and I'm excited for their future little
family oh I don't know if I ship them
OTP like I you don't think you don't
think that they're OTP that like no
matter who the other one dates they're
always just gonna come back to each
other no I never got that vibe also like
it's hard for me to report on these
stories like reading blinds like
thinking what I think about them but
then also you never know what the blinds
are saying but the blinds are that you
know he's you know very toxic has a lot
of substance abuse problems like so I
and that he's very controlling so when I
think of my brain in the blinds I'm like
oh no you know maybe it's not so good
but then like what I see on Instagram
it's all very sweet the Met Gala like
it's all nice and good so I don't know I
really don't know what today I think
happy thoughts and also like maybe this
will be the thing that makes them
together forever like we're not gonna go
do other things with other people
anymore yeah this could be the glue that
holds them together I don't know who I
thought Gigi's OTP was because it
definitely was not Joe Jonas honestly
part of me really believed it was Cody
Simpson because they just looked so much
alike and they were gonna become this
Australian power couple but I don't know
I never I never gave thought as to who
was her one true pair but um I just
never a suit I never just I I don't know
I dug Zayn was like a phase for her know
he's her one true pair and it's just
like Bella and the weekend you know they
they can't quit each other
yeah Bella and the weekend don't give me
as toxic a vibe yeah but they don't give
me as OTP a vibe like I just feel like
Gigi saying are so like obsessed with
each other meant to be obviously they
have obstacles and hurdles and whatever
challenges that you're suggesting but
they're gonna get through them together
because that's what OTPs do I guess I
don't know I'm not feeling like the
honeymoon vibe that you're feeling I
just I'm just like yeah I know this is
really shocking and really crazy and
obviously it's a rumor still because she
hasn't confirmed it so it's kind of like
sophie turner where it's just like being
reported as fact it's shocking to the
core
except i was really more shocking this
time the to like marrying couples
whereas joe and gigi used to date and
then it was like so toxic because she
left him for zayn and then like he was
all butthurt on instagram like posting
about it like I'm kind of living that
like these things are happening parallel
to each other yeah me too
and like who knows maybe they'll live in
the same town and their kids will go to
school together and then like date her
be friends that would be so crazy I mean
it reminds me of Kylie a lot cuz I think
a lot of people are thinking like Gigi
Hadid like height of her career biggest
supermodel in the world like getting
pregnant is not really like a part of
that plan but I think at some point it's
just like you've made all the money you
can like it's only so much money you can
make and there's only so many campaigns
you could do where it's like you want to
do something different and being a
mother is definitely different for sure
and I think Gigi is really
family-oriented like I think she's
obsessed with her family I could see if
like this is exactly what she wants um
and she is the biggest model of the
world I don't think there's anything
that she hasn't done or anything she's
like trying to it like she's I think it
gives you that sort of perspective when
you're on top looking down and you're
just like what do I want out of life
what makes me happy my family my man
let's make a family with my man ya know
it's literally like the Kiley syndrome
yeah except Kylie was 19
oh so much younger but Kylie was also
like a billionaire well not back then
but you know yeah it's not about money
well it's it's definitely about money I
think a lot of people plan their lives
around like excuse me a lot of people
plan like when they're gonna start a
family's based on like financials it's
like a huge part of that when you don't
have to think about it it's like sure
whatever yeah but I think Kylie was
another one who just really like always
dreamed of being a mom you know well
that's what she said in that YouTube
video that she put together and all of
her friends were like Kylie's always
want to be mom
as someone who's following her like I
never knew that but of course I don't
know her personally yeah I just I think
that it's true because I don't think and
anyone could make that up like it's your
Eddie mom like you don't need to justify
if I said you always wanted to be a mom
you know can you hang tight for once I
got my feet are so cold I'm just gonna
get a pair of socks right here 10
seconds you can sit forever
oh no I'll just get into the next story
because it's a it's a great segue it's a
little more bad news centered around the
GG because Shahs of Sunset star Golnesa
gives birth to a baby boy
congratulations are in order the Shahs
of Sunset star gave birth to her first
child a son named Eliza Javad gar how do
you pronounce her last name G G on
Monday night her rep confirmed to page
six on Tuesday Elisha arrived at 8:50
p.m. weighing in at 6.5 pounds and
measuring 19.5 inches page six can
exclusively reveal that her sister Leila
was with her at the hospital her rep
said everyone is doing great and Golnesa
is beyond excited to be a mom and start
this new adventure so I caught up on
some last weekend and so I think a lot
of people I was reading stuff in the
toasters people were very confused
because she's not really liked so like
the shah's people are interesting
because people watch them on TV but they
don't really keep up with their lives
like offline unless there's like major
drama so a lot of people were confused
because in most the most recent episodes
of Shahs um GG had miscarried and then
she had had an ectopic pregnancy where
they had to remove one of her fallopian
tubes so she could never get pregnant
naturally um ever again in her life and
a lot of people didn't know she was
pregnant I was seeing like some of my
friends but who watch the show and loved
the show they're like wait she's
pregnant um because she did go through
IVF which it's now my understanding I'm
learning so much that it bypasses the
fallopian tube so you can get IVF if you
don't have fallopian tubes so I'm so
happy for like this journey was so sad
like I knew that she was pregnant
starting the season and I knew that she
was gonna document the journey so when
she got pregnant this season I just
assumed it was a pregnancy I was seeing
on Instagram but I didn't know you
experienced a miscarriage and like it
was just so sad and I I've had my fair
share of problems with Loch NESA over
the years in terms of the show but to me
like her now wanting to get pregnant and
just like growing up so much like not
really involving herself a little bit
with the MJ stuff but I don't know I
just I really am seeing and every year
different housewives the reality stars
like renewed versions of themselves and
there it's a lie but I actually feel
like Loch NESA is no more hopefully yeah
I would agree with all of that she's
really grown up I'm so happy for her
this is something that she's wanted for
a long time and she manifested and it's
here and the baby he's here and he's
beautiful
yeah and she just like wanted a baby and
like went out and did everything she
could to get one like I just think
that's so impressive and tada that's
what I love about the shah's like they
really open up and bleed out for the
show like not because they're thirsty
but because they genuinely like want to
share their culture their experience
their fertility struggles with the
audience and I just think that like that
show is stellar and I'm all caught up
and I'm so conflicted like I there's a
little bit more to what MJ did but it's
not even close to deserving of the
response that it got from everyone but
particularly from Reza and Reza like
before three episodes ago I was about to
be completely finished with him like he
was so not self aware acting a fool but
he he came back down to earth and he was
really just trying to defend his husband
and like I respect that even though his
husband is towards character on the show
they need to wait me retweet retweet
good for each other and this whole thing
is Adams fault and then Adam like runs
away and he's not even a main character
it's just and Reza's like acting a mess
just because he's defending a system
which you and I would both do like I
totally respect that but he made it's
just awful like and and I'm a little
over destiny like my things are really
changing but the only thing not changing
is that Nima absolutely has to go but he
did one good thing he he's like a
Content strategist I don't know what he
does but one of his clients for his fake
business was boots and brews a country
music festival in LA and he made all the
the crew like dress up and they're like
these Persian like 40 year olds dressed
up as cowgirls going to a festival like
eating mac and cheese and ribs like it
was so funny like them in that setting
was pure reality TV gold and Reza's
broth I mean Nima brought them there so
for that I'll allow it but like him
talking about his struggles with his mom
and the letter like I don't care I mean
oh that's so rude but like I don't know
you I barely know you
I don't know what this letter your mama
you when she's play you and your sister
up like the parents right it's it's so
hard to care about like
reality stars like it's just this this
interesting formula of like enough time
and not too much time because I do want
to know some stuff about you in order to
give two shits about you but like just
be Garcelle or go home
yeah or be Leah McSweeney like I know
nothing about Leah McSweeney but like
when she goes deep like I'm kind of into
it same with Garcelle talking about like
her husband like that's interesting your
mom dropping you off at a nunnery Leah
McSweeney that's interesting so I
randomly that you brought her up I was
reading yesterday about the article that
she wrote for about the women's March um
first I read like a post article about
like recapping the article and then I
was like let me read her actual work
like I know who that she's a writer um
it's so crazy you should read it no that
is so impressive a verb and it's crazy
that she was cast for Real Housewives of
New York and and II didn't know that
that's like probably number first thing
on her resume right like a list of
accomplishments yeah cries um also you
just talking about like boots and barns
festival um they can literally gives me
a pit in my stomach because it's all I
want to be doing like I am just I'm
broken and my time hop this week is last
year stagecoach two years before that
our family trip to Turks and Caicos like
every time I log on to time up I want to
throw my three years three years before
that stagecoach so right just like never
ending oh my god it's I mean it's so
upsetting
I miss fun so much time wearing my
serpaj sweatshirt just like an honorary
fun memento of the times that we had at
surf I remember when you overpaid for
that sweatshirt but it was so worth it
well no so this is I overpaid for to
surf walk sweatshirt so this one was
worth because it's actually cool the
other one that I got is hideous except
that it until I pulled this one out from
the back of my closet it was the only
zip up that I had we need to make a zip
up because sometimes you don't need
something over your head I agree next
row okay
next shop we're making a sip up like I
don't always want to put something over
my face over my thought and I was
wearing like a sport like in the queue
I'm experimenting with different styles
so I was wearing a sports bra and this
oversized sweater like I thought I was
ariana grande in the queue and I just
feel like that's an aesthetic that
should elaborate and because like when I
drink when I'm like just sitting on the
couch drinking my first leaf wine I
really fluctuate temperature-wise and to
have to take a sweatshirt hoodie on and
off and on and off it's a lot as if up
let me maybe drag it down on my
shoulders huh this like isn't a real
sports bra like if I go any further like
you that's what we need it to see me I'm
like okay soma no this is um Calvin
Klein but it's legit made of nothing
well just picture this you guys you're
at home finishing a glass of wine and
just as you're about to pour another it
happens the realization that you're all
out and there's no backup bottle we call
that no vino phobia the fear of running
out of wine thanks diversely if we get
personalized boxes of wine shipped right
to our door here so you can get the
incredible wine without leaving the
comfort of your own home start by taking
a quiz to assess your wine drinking
preferences then first leaf we'll send
six expertly picked bottles of wine to
your house based on your answers the
cool part is that they use your ratings
and feedback to refine your future
shipments so you just give a little
thumbs up or thumbs down every time
firstly will take care of the rest you
can also choose what types of wine you
want your next box they update their
inventory every month so you always have
something new to try their subscriptions
are super flexible so you can choose
when and how often to get shipments
firstly it has a 100% satisfaction
guarantee so if you receive a bottle
that you aren't into for sleep we'll
cover the cost the idea of a wine
subscription service is so genius like
on a normal you know everyday day but
being in quarantine like I think the
amount of times if I didn't have firstly
if I would have to go run out to the
liquor store and it's a central business
thank God so they're still open but just
like not having to have that errand to
run and just knowing that there's
another bottle is so important to me yes
sign up today concur sign up today to
get six bottles of wine for only $29.95
plus free shipping just go to try first
leaf dot-com slash toast that's six
bottles of wine for only twenty nine
ninety-five at try first leaf dot-com
slash toast
thank you for sleep for sponsoring this
episode and just for being everything we
need in the queue one hundred and ten
percent
okay next story um I'm like so here for
it I just I don't know if you've seen it
yet but I'm just here for it because
Nick Miele
is slamming Madison Pruett over like how
she's behaving on social media calling
her a liar now I guess he like went on a
bit of a rant and I read this article
and I'm just like here for someone
speaking the truth
not that I think Madison is liar not a
liar but someone just like knowing
something and saying what's what they
know you know so here's what um here's
what Nik vile
said he was discussing Madison Pruitt's
recent claims that Peter Weber wanted to
rekindle their relationship days before
sparking romance rumors with Kelly
Flanagan Nick shared that she that
Madison has a reputation of being quote
a liar he also alleged that fan theories
calling out Madison for running her own
fan account which fans believe she used
to depict herself in a positive light
are true we all remember that when her
account was comforting okay so he said
we also he said quote this is next words
we also know Madison to be a bit of a
liar people want to forget I know
Madison wants to forget it but her
Instagram it's a fact she did that and
listen it is silly and trivial and
there's a logical explanation for it
that you know she wanted people to like
her it's a totally relatable thing he
said I'm more critical of that and I
know Madison thinks I don't like her and
I know people think I've been hard on
Madison I think she's just fine I've
even defended Madison but if you're
going to be righteous and you're going
to be pious and you're going to be like
talk about your relationship with God
and how you want to be an example to
young women blah blah blah I hold you to
a high standard so don't be a liar don't
be vain I'm vain I can be Dane don't
have your family use Bruce pearls house
for your hometown and sell it as your
own home when it's not your home before
wrapping up the ad yep before wrapping
up he added I don't like that if you're
going to be super pious I've talked to
producers and they like Madison but they
also think she can be a little
manipulative and a little bit of a liar
oh my god the tea I just burped my lip
wait he also weighed in on that
tick-tock video which fueled Feud rumors
between her and Kelly this month when um
she posted that you know the make up
thing and then they were like where's
Peter where Kelly Kelly right and Nick
said every bachelor goes through it
we're like especially the bottom three
women on your season love to like
they're starving for attention he says
like more than we do
you know like all these girls that
popped up on Madison snapchat or
tick-tock whatever the [ __ ] she was
doing to get headlines like Peters women
throw shade to Peter like he gets
annoying right they have literally no
connection to him whatsoever so true I
mean I think that Nick vile has really
cemented himself as a truth teller and a
moral compass of the bachelor nation
community so I have absolutely no choice
but to believe everything he just said
and I agree I mean a Madison has been
pissing me off like since the day she
left and I defended her like I thought
barb was an [ __ ] and I still do but
like I just thought Madison handed
herself with grace and she really was
just like pious innocent like really
nice but then just like something about
the tick tocks and now knowing that her
house was fake like I can't and I shut
oh and I went yeah yeah Nick violet just
like he holds up a mirror to bachelor
nation and he's and cuz it's cuz he's
not like he doesn't pretend to be
something that he's not he's he's like
been in everyone's shoes and and he sees
what they're doing and I really
appreciate someone just telling us okay
like Madison is it like she's probably a
nice girl but like she's not as perfect
no one is that perfect you know right
and there's been so much mystery around
this whole situation like everyone's
speaking in such like weird spooky ways
like there's so much you don't know we
know more happens like and so we're just
just you hate that [ __ ]
and we're just supposed to assume
there's so much more that we don't know
but no one will tell us but they'll just
tell us that there's more that we don't
know it's so frustrating so it really
has been a confusing time for like Peter
Sam's and Madison's because someone's
[ __ ] lying and I think that
unfortunately and I don't even like
Peter like I hate to even defend him
because he was the worst bachelor in
history but I do think that Maddie is a
little snaky vibes yeah I don't like
like Peter I didn't enjoy his season but
I feel like at this point lay off of him
but he's just trying to enjoy his life
and by the way if he is with Kelly now
and she's everything of the sort like he
figured his [ __ ] out he made it right
with her and he's okay in my book great
speaking I'm right um speaking of all
this if you want more a dirty head over
this to the snaps or she just dropped a
new episode all about listen to your
hearts last year snatch it really
honestly is so important
to your snatch sometimes though and
that's what I kind of have learned about
my body during the process of this
quarantine it's like not only is it so
important to listen to your body and
every influence right now taught me that
but it is more important than anything
to listen to her sach 1,000%
so did you wind up listening to your
body life yesterday and taking a nap no
I meant to mention that in the beginning
but I forgot so I know everyone's been
like waiting with bated breath I woke up
early yesterday yeah your sleep schedule
has just been we're losing sleep over it
yeah and I know everyone wants to know
like to eat at work I were you up all
night no I've been going I've been going
to bed at like 1:00 and laying there
till 3:00
me and Ben went to bed at 1:00 and I
passed the [ __ ] out and today again I
woke up I'm waking up an hour and a half
before the show I just think it's like
what I need to like lay around before
the show and to reset my body to get in
this good groove and I was so tired
yesterday like literally I got up to
make dinner
my legs were trembling maybe that's
because I haven't gotten out of bed in
like two weeks but I literally was like
been give me water I was being so
dramatic in the kitchen like them thank
you
I didn't take it he's like so done with
me by the way he is yeah well I got new
sheets from Brooklyn and shout out I
paid for them but they're really really
good and I realized how like gray my
white sheets were until I got new white
ones and I put them on that's why it's
like a little [ __ ] up over there but
um I asked him to help me with the duvet
cover and he was like I have an 11
o'clock meeting like so do i toast and
I'm like just if we do it together we
could do it in four minutes but like
I'll be doing it here for 15 minutes
alone so like the first second I'm like
grab this corner and he's just like he's
not listening he said grabbing some
random corner like I put the duvet cover
on the bed two days ago um and just like
after doing everything that I've now
learned to do in the queue they do babe
cover was a walk in the park I'm dealing
with clean stuff like it's yeah that
comfortable it just gives you
perspective you know but you know what
my new cross to bear is in the cleaning
realm and like this is might sound gross
but apparently it's like a thing my
towels like don't smell good when they
come out of the laundry anymore they
smell and I was peloton yesterday I have
like a stack of little wash cloth towels
for my face and they smell like gym
clothes even though they're fresh and I
looked it up and it's called smelly
towel syndrome as one um
as one cleaning blogger closet and
basically like the towels like because
they're so absorbent they soak up all of
the like fabric softener and detergent
and then they don't rinse out so I need
to get like white wine vinegar and
baking soda to relieve all my towels so
that's my chore today so I had a similar
problem but it wasn't with my towels it
was just like any time I would wash
something I would open the washer door
and like it was just smelling vibes and
it's just yeah it's just that your
washing machine is smelly like you need
to clean your washing machine so you
have to run an empty cycle with white
wine vinegar which worked instantly now
I'm having that problem with my
dishwasher I open up the dishwasher
[ __ ] smells why are all the
appliances so problematic
well it makes sense they're wet and dry
and then wet and then moist and it's
like in the dishwasher disgusting
you know the I well I've had that issue
with my laundry machine I always suspect
it's a smelling machine I just like I
don't trust it but my clothes don't
smell just my towels smell like gym
clothes so it's I'm gonna experiment
let's make sure that it's only your
towels well no it makes sense as this
actually have the page up here
the bloggers it's one good thing by
Jilly she said it's because the towels
like the way they absorb so much so they
about and I've been using too much
fabric softener on my towels you're not
supposed to use any fabric softener
because um I was using it cause I just
was like oh I'll have soft towels but no
or don't use it don't use any fabric
softener because pretty much like the
towels absorb all that they don't get
rid of it and now it's holding on and
eventually like cleaning products like
soap turns to dirt when not washed out
so I'm gonna I'm just having a brick
softener you can use it on everything
else but just not on your towels I'm a
delivery to all my towels yesterday and
I put in so much fabric softener [ __ ]
well eventually I'll just have to do a
load of white wine vinegar with your
towels and then a load of baking soda on
hot if it's bad and I'll let you guys
know clothes I also need new towels does
anyone else treat their towels like [ __ ]
like my towels are literally disposable
like I throw them in the wash and they
change colors because I don't care and
then I got my makeup all over them and
then in like a year I just get rid of it
and I got new ones yeah I was like
thinking about I was reading this
article I was like why don't people just
get new towels and they start to smell
like gym clothes but I realize now it's
like every single one of my towels like
I would
paulus well also some people really
invest in their towels like they get
plush huge like no minor like camp level
piece-of-shit towels because I literally
just it's a cycle like I just disposed
of that and they're from Target yeah
also I do have some like plush towels
that are monogrammed that I got as
wedding gifts but I don't use them like
I don't think what's not those are
decorative makeup on them no I there for
my like real adult house you know oh
yeah oh my name is life I have so much
[ __ ] that is like for my married house
and like technically I've been married
for three years and I live in this house
for three years don't care I will not
use like my KitchenAid like um food
processor like the bread maker thing
like that is for my house in the suburbs
if I ever go yeah like those towels are
for bad like when I have a house with
bathrooms that I don't use so that way
I'm not like but in my master bathroom I
will never be using like plush ass like
monogrammed towels no like what I do to
my towels is absolutely disgusting like
you don't even want to know the places
they go the things that they say and
like the things that get swiped on them
so I can't I don't understand people who
have like fancy like cashmere towels
yeah that they use like on the regular
look in their blood home their legs I've
actually never done that move like I
think men do that yeah
Gooch it's my understanding it been left
make sense not to be like so gross but
when bigots had the shower he like
always had a shower I'm laying in bed he
just like looks at me like I'm supposed
to do something and then I watch him dry
off and he like literally takes a towel
and like shoves it but in between is
John Kasich and that's how he gets to
try so he doesn't do but like the little
air dry my thing understood well that's
nice okay next story are you ready are
you ready kids okay kendall Jenner is
quarantine road trippin with NBA's Devin
Booker Kendall Jenner has a special
quarantine pal and be a superstar Devin
Booker and they just social distance in
the back of his may Bach together for a
quick quick road trip to Sedona
TMZ sports has fitted footage of the two
of them during a quick bathroom break at
a rest stop near the ours
city and it's not like they were trying
to keep a low profile okay so like one
this sounds like a dream just going on a
quarantine road trip to Sedona which I
thought was wine country but I guess
it's Arizona I thought it was one
country like in I think Sonoma Sonoma
it could be wine country but just in
Arizona
maybe I don't know I thought it was
whatever I thought so too but I guess
not and you know what now that I think
about it um that was so like I can't
remember last time I heard something
about them like girls gotta live you
know totally I mean Kendall nearly has
like terrible taste in men
except for Harry Styles but like some of
the guys she dates I just I don't I
don't get it
yeah we missed I said that they looked
like a couple during the stop at sources
close to Devin and Kendall insists
they're just friends one source puts it
this way quote Kendall and Friends have
a small social circle amongst the group
who have been following the same social
distancing and physical distancing
guidelines Devin is a friend and as part
of that small group they took a road
trip to much-needed air you know but
like this is like controversial like cuz
Ness is like it's not really a necessary
errand to like drive to Phoenix um so
it's like first people are reading this
story like oh look new boyfriend and
then it's like wait we're in the middle
of a pandemic where you going no I don't
like I'm sorry I can't judge you if I
had a car and a interesting place to go
and I could get there like knowing that
I could handle myself and just drive um
I would be there in a flash totally I
wish I had a car I mean I don't like
people are doing drive up graduations
drive up birthday parties I think
getting in a car and going somewhere is
completely fine yeah I agree I think the
car is safe I think the car is safe too
also he's one of the top players in the
NBA he's currently in a middle of a
five-year 158 million dollar contract
with the Suns so I love that for her Oh
even though I can't see it Oh
even though TMZ is saying like yes
Kendall does have her circle of friends
and they're you know certainly I've
never heard of this guy in the group
before like he's no Faye no and also
like I have a husband who knows
everything about the NBA and I just know
players because I've heard their name
but I have never heard of this guy I
don't know what he looks like but if you
got a hundred million dollar contract
giving those out in the NBA like he's
obviously legit what's his name Devin
Booker he sounds cute
I literally have no idea what he looks
I'm trying to picture um well the
pictures of them out and about are like
not great quality but I'm really here
for this like I just I'm glad she's
finding love in the queue so hot okay
now I'm gonna look at Matt oh my god
baby so cute wait I'm dead I take back
what I said about a Tootsie look at this
smile he has perfect teeth you think
those are veneers no oh those oh he's a
major cutie 100 so 158 158 mil wait so
you he king of speaking of millions
Kylie has been in her new house like
tick-tocking around the house with Stas
just like you said she would
yes I'm so happy it's like she's putting
out content because she wants us to know
that she's in the new house because
she's taking pictures and videos in the
most recognizable parts of the house
from the pictures that went around on
our Instagram and on TMZ like her and
and it looks like it's the furniture
from the pictures yeah no and I feel
like maybe she's not totally moved in
like she might even just be going back
and forth and stuff but what a fun time
to get a new swanky pad and she looks so
sickening
that's all motion video that she put on
her Instagram trying to sell Kylie skins
gun screen like I was [ __ ] hooked
like I literally have that Sun screen
and I want to buy it again her blonde
hair is so beautiful like she is living
the life and she's just like walking
around creating tick-tocks I just I live
for a culturally relevant kylie queen i
know it's it's so good it's so good
um speaking of Kylie though an
interesting factoid because you know
that stormy loves trolls do you know
that they release trolls like at home
and it made more money in like the first
few weeks and it did in five months in
theaters like the first one so now that
that makes work parents just need their
kids to like shut the [ __ ] up and they
like put on trolls and the kids are
quiet for two hours honestly yeah it's
it was very kind of the studio not to
postpone because there are parents I bet
needed trolls to come out no even in the
background of Kylie's tic TOCs like
trolls world tours up on the queue in
her TV
that's so cute look what was he
equivalent for us of like a franchise
cartoon that we like died for Shrek oh
maybe but we were it would be younger
than I honestly it was like Barney yeah
Barney was the [ __ ]
wait so here's a stat the troll sequel
made more money in three weeks of
digital release than the original did in
five months in theaters Wow we can be uh
not in my newsletter but it led
NBCUniversal CEO Jeff Schell to say the
direct release option could be a new
business model for big-budget films even
once the pandemic is over that in turn
caused AMC to the movie theater chain to
say that it won't play any Universal
films in its theaters so now there's
like beef but you know what I do see
that definitely opening up as like a
revenue stream maybe not for every film
like I don't think people want to watch
scary movies at home but I think there's
probably a really interesting like
business opportunity for kids movies
like parents can't always get out and
take their kids to the movies and kids
are just so [ __ ] in a way like always
need to have to do so actually think it
could be great yeah I think that's
really interesting and them I'm I'm
happy for the kids that I'm happy for
the parents and this is actually a great
segue into our fifth and final story
that's a little movie biz news it's a
little movie big yes are you ready for
it
mhm you don't have anything that you
want to say okay Oscars will consider
films that didn't play in theaters as
part of new academy rules so the Academy
of Motion Picture Arts and Sciences has
tweaked its
oscar eligibility rules in the wake of
the kern of iris pandemic during a
meeting on Tuesday the Board of
Governors approved a temporary hold on
the requirement that a film needs a
seven-day theatrical run in commercial
in a commercial theater in Los Angeles
County to qualify for the Oscars what a
layman world to begin with yeah that's
why the Irishman was like in theaters
before it was on Netflix cuz they just
gonna this seems like it it needed to go
anyway instead films will be allowed to
be released digitally without
playing in theaters however that doesn't
mean any movie premiering on a streaming
service is eligible for Oscar gold to be
considered the streamed film Esav
already had a plan theatrical release
the film must also be made available on
the Academy screening room member only
streaming site within 60 days of the
film streaming or VOD release they're
still so backwards like you select a
plant like get with the times
you know this rule is obviously still in
place but for coronavirus it can't be
saying you need to have had something
planned in theatres in order to be
eligible but there's no talk about good
moving forward if this rule is going to
be eradicated because it's such an
antiquated rule yeah seriously and
they're still trying to like make this
royal happen and it's like it's 2020 you
know cuz technically like to all the
boys I loved before is not nominated not
being able to be nominated for an Oscar
it's not eligible and I just think
that's [ __ ] up yeah oh it's at is that
true like I it just is a good movie it's
a good movie it wasn't released in
theaters and it should be honestly some
of the [ __ ] they nominate for Oscars to
all the boys they loved before it's a
perfect movie III would agree with that
oh by by an answer to your question I'm
the studio revealed that trolls world
tour took in 100 million dollars in
premium VOD rentals in its first three
weeks of play in North America that's
crazy
crazy now I want to watch it I actually
did see trolls one so I might as well
see you like the good one you know kids
movies that like kids love Pixar such
like a brilliant company because they
are really also made for adults I did me
and then actually recently re-watched
Shrek when I was like a young child I
loved it but it's actually there's two
shows going on there's like the show for
kids and then there's like the double
entendres that are actually for adults
yeah maybe I'll string it out it's I'm
should be Vanderpump rules let's well
the Vanderpump rules freak app segment
is brought to you by Nature iam driven
by the belief that high-end performance
skin care should be and can be non-toxic
skin compatible and affordable nutriyum
was born their mission is to create safe
clinically effective biocompatible
products that deliver visible results
all of their products range from just
sixteen to twenty five dollars yet
they're as effective as formulas that
are triple or in some cases eighteen
times the price nutrient formulas
utilize cutting-edge technology to
the healing powers of ingredients found
in nature there are their products
proudly made in the USA cruelty free
paraben free gluten free non-toxic
fragrance free and dermatologist tested
and Jackie and I have both been using
many of the products from the natatorium
line for like three weeks now I don't
know time is so arbitrary and weird but
it's been a while it's been like seven
weeks for me I'm obsessed honestly I was
just saying this to my skin and the
queue it's like poppin and I think it's
because of my new natori I'm routine I'm
using the retinol products at night and
then vitamin C products now in the
morning after someone suggested that I
do that and then instead of switching
off every day and their multi peptide
eye cream like is it just me or am i
looking younger you're looking great
they believe it's impossible to achieve
healthy nourish skin with formulas that
are unbalanced or incompatible they only
use ingredients that either directly
benefit the skin's health or support the
integrity of their formulations they're
offering a special promo code for all
toasters to receive the free multi
peptide eye cream that jackie was just
talking about with any purchase of two
items or more so at Natori Imam add an
eye cream to any purchase of two items
or more if you use the code toast you'll
receive the eye cream for no cost so
that's not areum na tu RI you m.com
get two items that get a free eye cream
with the code toast TOA st Thank You
deter iam Vanderpump rules I'm so is
finally before we clean up came to a
head with stassi's engagement and I was
so grateful that they got engaged in the
first twenty minutes and they didn't
wait till the end but I was about to
really get annoyed when I thought that
they were gonna do that mmm-hmm it was
so hot we yeah it was really cute like
Stassi really didn't know and she was
like shut the [ __ ] up that was really
cute and but was so cute and it was
really well planned and I like when
there's more than just like there's a
thought that goes into it like the
mausoleum which is so saucy like I don't
understand it but it's so saucy and it
was very very sweet yeah and the party
was really nice and there was also like
it was all the OGS like getting together
for like a real occasion and that's just
like what I love to see Lisa's house
looked so pretty my favorite part was
when like Stassi was like so happy she
just saw her family and Lisa was like I
have a white dress for you like if you
want to wear it and so he was like I
feel great
you know yep Stassi was like how
everyone should be like she just didn't
care about anything she didn't really
care about the Carter stuff she
just so elated and so happy and it
really was like lovely to see cuz we
have been like on the journey for eight
seasons of like all the boyfriends
Jack's like it's really been quite
tumultuous um and just to see it kind of
come full circle was really nice yeah it
was really nice I mean they did sort of
make the day about like Kristyn and
Carter drama but I think that was just
the show doing that I'm sure for them it
was like 0.5 seconds of their day um
yeah all the drama like really is so
crazy I'm really am feeling for Kristen
and I and I understand it's it's totally
stassi's day and whatever she wants like
she should have but it must be just
really sad to be in Kristin's shoes
right now and just like the people that
have been through there for like through
all the hardships of like the last 15
years of being single and figuring life
out and saying now you're all like
hitting your stride and you can't even
be there to celebrate I don't know I
just like well did she even do at this
point to make it better but then also
but then also she's like depressed so
she's calling her man to come and get
her dogs and it's like if you really
want to like you need to choose now your
friends work harder which person which
people are your future and like the fact
that she keeps like it's about Carter
and she cook keeps going back to Carter
she's not helping herself I know but I
don't really agree with the the position
she's being put in like she couldn't
want to be friends with her friends of
15 years and still be like a like silly
with Carter like she's making the wrong
choice for sure with Carter but like I
don't know why it has to be one or the
other and it was really sad like
honestly Sheena being at Stassi
engagement was like so random like
they're really not friends
Sheena's part of this like new
generation of Sur staff she was at the
softball game so like just seeing her
there was really kind of like a gut
punch and then like even Lala who I
believe had fine intentions calling
Kristen like I'm sure Chris didn't want
to hear from this girl who's been around
for three years and just like is rolling
in as the girl who knew that Stassi was
getting engaged and Kristen's friend is
Sassy's friend of fifteen years and had
no idea and found out on Instagram like
I understood why she was kind of being a
[ __ ] salawa ya know but I don't think
that's fair because la la' is very much
like in their group of friends it would
be like if Britney called Kristen
Brittany's been around for the same
amount of time but like they're all on
on the same page now a friendship and as
far as scheana goes yet her and Stassi
like
not close but they have been like on
they started like this show together
they've given it their all I think they
have neutral respect for one another and
Sheena deserve to be there even though
she is like joining the younger
generation she's still part of the og
cast and I think it was very nice and
she was included because you'd meet you
if that means to her and she's done
nothing but like try and be cool with
everyone um so I did think that that was
that was sweet
me too I feel for Sheena I like
especially with last week's episode like
I don't know what her motive is in any
of this I gotta know what she wants to
get out of the show but part of me likes
he's like these weirdly earnest moments
with her and like I feel for her yeah I
me too but I just thought the episode
last night at least for the OGS was
really sweet as far as the softball game
goes I was so glad that Sur beat Tom Tom
like I was totally Teamster I didn't
even realize like just Tom and then even
the other time when he's with the first
time they just are annoying like I'm
Justin yeah and honestly smacks
individually I don't like live for every
single girl but like having like Dana
scheana Charlie like all them together
Raquel like I was on their side I was
like yes get your pink socks and win a
hundred percent like I really like
Raquel charlie is like funny and she has
done nothing to upset me um even Danica
like is growing on me you do and I love
Dana and that's my team now so I guess
it's good it's it's making me feel like
loyal towards the new people as opposed
to the old people yes I was like trying
to explain to ban like what was
happening cuz he like didn't understand
the show he like has seen episodes but
now it's like a totally different show
and I'm like these are the new people
I'm like I really like them like now I
kind of like them like I really do I
think Dana really was a great cast
because she made me like give the new
kids um a shot to begin with because she
was the only one who was Terrell
tolerable at first totally and also when
all of the new kids were talking about
how Stassi got engaged it's like
literally how the freshman like talk
about the senior is like oh we got to go
to prom like it was it's like and any
time I feel I feel like I do have
something good happens for the for the
seniors the freshmen get like so excited
because they're like
oh my senior year like that will happen
for us too yeah that could be us yeah
like even with the wine they were
talking about how the wine was so good
I'm sure just like it makes them excited
to be on the show and and all the
possibilities that could happen for them
if they stay the course so it was like a
boring episode but not a bad episode
like some of the episodes recently have
just felt so stage and overproduced and
just like not hump rules vibe at all
this one was good like it Katy was being
funny at the softball game that's
exactly how I would have acted I really
I'm like happy about James because I
know once again like so many reality
stars every season like it's an anime
but now we're a year out and we know
that he's like almost a year sober and
I'm just really happy for him and I feel
like Katy not where we're at in the show
right now but like a few months later I
remember her like posting about him on
it on her Instagram like saying she was
proud of him like things do get better
for everyone in James and that much I'm
looking forward to yeah I agree with
that I'm very much looking for excited
also this episode made me crave so many
things about about real life like those
salads at Villa Rosa
like all I want is a fresh salad all I
want oh my god I'm like my mouth is
watering and I'm gonna kiss a little
compressor oh my god Lala's nails were
sickening umm dress oh my god she's just
and everyone just like who was at I
think what was nice about like the Villa
Rosa thing it was like everyone it
wasn't up her obviously it was like they
were filming whatever but it wasn't a
production we're gonna talk about this
it was just everyone was existing being
who they are in 2019 and everyone's in a
really good place who was there and it
was just a night it seems like a nice
place to be and one like Stassi and Beau
we're like walking towards the cliff and
they were like this is the best day of
my life I was just like so jealous of
their happiness you know and just like
their ability to be outside and their
ability to be outside and like looking
over this beautiful Vista and talking
about how they're gonna have this tour
one day because like - des is just like
not but my Vista is a back alley yes
actually it is I know my department
looks into a back alley my Vista is
someone else's apartment that's nice -
mmm okay let's jump into - your toasters
our advice segment where we talk about
anything from quarantine stuff to
wedding stuff boyfriend stuff whatever
you need we always keep it anonymous you
can email us dear toasters at gmail.com
and here is our first one hit Claudia
and Jackie I have a seriously bad
situation right now I'm 20 back at home
right now for the quarantine my mom went
on my dad's phone in front of me and
found a sugar daddy website where he had
a profile there there were no messages
but still that was a whole thing and
because I was in the room with her I am
now involved since it is very weird in
the house now they're working on their
relationship and whatnot one night after
a few Clause I went on my dad his phone
because he left it in the kitchen
unattended I decided to check his texts
and it was clear that I went on to
Facebook messages and saw some [ __ ] I
can never unsee basically I can see that
he either for real in person cheated on
my mom or he at least has been messaging
other women sending pictures etc my mom
is a peach almond doesn't deserve this
but if they were to fight about this now
and I would be in the house while the
fire burns it also legit will not feel
bad for my dad because he's been a piece
of [ __ ] and it's constantly commenting
on my weight how much what I'm eating
what I'm drinking etc he means well but
he's incredibly ignorant what the [ __ ]
should I do
should I tell my mom and make my
quarantine more dramatic or should I
wait to tell her and show her the proof
that I have that sounds like a [ __ ]
piece of work I remember one time in my
life
one time in my life daddy like mentioned
something about my weight because I had
like gained a lot of weight and like
came out in a bikini at Grammys house
that was like the bikini I wore when I
was like literally 50 pounds lighter and
he was like he just was like he was just
like physically shy cooked by like the
way that he was like what and I'm like I
never forgot it it's [ __ ]
traumatizing I literally yelled at him
so bad so honestly your dad if he's
doing it constantly like you're so
busily upset he sounds like an [ __ ]
oh my god that is so crazy I think that
you should tell your mom because she's
gonna need support and to do it when
she's alone after the Q like you should
be there for her like you need to step
up as a daughter and get messy and
uncomfortable but like your mom needs to
know and she she's a peach arm she
shouldn't have to like be alone and I
understand it's not unlike the children
to deal with this but like you're an
adult you're 20 years old and your mom
needs a girlfriend and you can be that
girl for her what about the route of you
taking the information to your dad and
saying I'm gonna tell mom if you don't
okay but still he tells mom in the queue
and then there's drama
the cue in the house and it's weird in
the house and it's in the house weird
it's Dana
it's the same and saying you know but
you don't even like your dad doesn't
even deserve that opportunity like just
[ __ ] tell your mom you don't have to
be like sneaky sadly like you know tell
her I'm going to and she's in the other
room like this is so interesting though
because it's really I'm shedding a light
on like kids our age who like have their
own lives but went home for quarantine
because their parents have like a bigger
house they have a pool you want to be in
the suburbs want to go to the city and
there's obviously so many benefits but
there's also some real detractors and I
don't know what the right call is like
if like people when it comes to tear
toasters people are rioting and like
really regret it going home yeah I think
ultimately the right choice is to go
home because I think you know the family
drama and like the you know what I would
imagine is like who's gonna clean up and
everyone's hunger case and that's
annoying but like to have that space and
a yard and a car is so great like for
your mental health I think being alone
in a city in New York Arman is just not
it so I think ultimately going home is
the right choice for most people yeah
okay next up to your toasters the other
night I got really drunk for the first
time in a while I started texting and
facetiming with an old hookup who I
hadn't seen or talked to for four years
because I've been in a relationship I
love my boyfriend more than anything I
feel so guilty for talking to another
guy behind his back especially a guy you
stuck up with am i making this into a
bigger deal and it is is it normal to
feel this guilty is this considered
cheating the face time was less than
five minutes and I don't even remember
what we talked about helped me feel
better about the situation or tell me
I'm a disgusting ho who needs Jesus
thank you
that's sick [ __ ] crazy because she
didn't say in the beginning she's in a
relationship she just said she knows
she's next I love my boyfriend like mmm
what very sighs here's the thing like
it's not cheating like don't beat
yourself up over it but like it's not
good like it's not great if your man was
doing that and you knew that like your
boyfriend of four years was like getting
drunk and calling an ex like the that
just like wouldn't make you feel good I
don't think you need to tell anyone or
come clean but like try not to do it
again yeah no I definitely don't do it
again but I would maybe suggest some
internal reflection because given the
fact that you got drunk and wanted to do
this could be harmless but it could mean
something else and also the way that you
worded your thing to us like makes
think that your relationship is like not
a priority but then she said she loves
her boyfriend more than anything and so
I just feel like there's a lie somewhere
I lied to yourself drunk actions could
be you know sober truths drunk me can't
get over you that's it and you know
we're in so much of snitching Tenpenny I
just feel like that I mean I just feel
like you [ __ ] like obviously they have a
pit about this as you should but it's
not the biggest seal but just like take
some time to think on it and be like
what do I really want yeah or take some
time to think like why did I do this
like there's a reason for everything
even if you're drunk like you're still
you yeah yeah some self-reflection would
be good here you got extra time in the
key oh I would suggest some of that yeah
is she not queueing with her man's
that's what I was thinking
I guess otherwise yeah interesante in
which case you're together four years
why aren't you in the key together right
I just think there's more here that
you're not unpacking so I'm trying to
open your suitcase and do for you yeah
but just don't be afraid they just dig
deep into your feelings and think about
what you want now is the time the queue
is gonna change things for people I
think people are realizing what life is
about
you know yep yep yep yep yep yep so true
so true life is what you make it so
let's make a rock let's and let's make
it rock with our third year toasters
which is a little bit of a long one so
stay with me let me just take some water
first hi Claudia and Jackie I'm a huge
toaster and I want to say thank you for
helping me get through this treacherous
time I'm 23 and my boyfriend's 25 we've
been dating for six months we were
quarantined together up until a week ago
we live in DC we are both working from
home until at least midnight
last week my boyfriend told me that he
wanted to go home he lives in Montana so
he had to fly obviously I was a little
taken aback because I didn't want to be
in my apartment alone for a month I
can't go home because my doesn't my mom
doesn't want me risking picking it up
during my flight and giving it to them
and I have a family that is high-risk I
explained this my boyfriend and he
didn't really get it his parents
chartered a private plane for him to get
home which is probably safer but
definitely not with in most people's
budgets I semi jokingly said that I
would
take a PJ who wouldn't and he said I
could come when I brought it up later
though he said he didn't think it was a
good idea I have him in his parents yet
he said it would be too stressful for
him to have me come back to Montana for
a few weeks I understand his reasoning
but these are unprecedented times and
while it might be awkward it's better
than being alone in my apartment for
over a month he left on Sunday and I
can't stop crying every time I talk to
him
he said he keeps saying how happy is to
be home and when I asked him when he
would come back to DC he said there's no
reason for me to be in DC um what about
me he left on Sunday I just said that
does this guy care about me at all I
thought he was a P John but I'm not sure
sure so sure now the fact that he just
left me in the dust as soon as his
parents sent him a private jet just
hurts I just kind of feel abandoned and
I don't think he gets why I'm so upset
and sad I don't know if I'll be able to
get over this and I just don't know what
I can do or say to figure out if he
really cares about me love you guys
girl with no PJ I just before I say
anything before is anything I would
strongly encourage both this girl and us
to try and make it work because if you
can get a husband who has a access to a
private jet that is just worth its
weight in gold that's okay totally did
she say how long they were together for
how long they've been together for six
months okay so it's a weird it's a weird
point it's like you're together long
enough that you guys are gonna
quarantine together and enjoy being able
to be together all the time but it's
like you still haven't met his family
enough to go home and live with them for
a few weeks and so on the one hand when
I'm reading this I'm like the quarantine
is weird unprecedented times and you if
you have a private jet and you have a
ranch in Montana it sounds like you
bring your girlfriend home with you and
you and you take these big steps forward
because the quarantine is pushing you
into those steps but on the other hand
like relationships especially new
relationships like are very delicate and
bringing your new girlfriend home to
meet your family and then essentially
live with you guys for a few weeks is
extreme it's not something that I would
do but I feel like I could under I
understand completely why you kind of
expected him to outreaches and be
generous with that invitation and and I
never really badly like that you're
alone um but I think it's very very
overeager for him to invite you to come
live with his family for a few weeks I'm
gonna be harsh I'm gonna be harsh
because I'm reading this as a totally
you know unbiased third-party
perspective just like reading
as to what's coming on and here's what
it sounds like it sounds like you were
dating this guy for six months it was
all fine and good
you quarantined together and I can make
maybe he just was over it in the
quarantine like it sounds like he didn't
want you to come because if you have a
girlfriend you're crazy about you not
only don't want to be away from her you
want progress he want to bring you home
to the cat the parents so I just feel
like maybe he changed his mind and
Quarantine like when you're dating
someone you're not used to spending at
the first six months seven weeks with
them and like maybe he's over it maybe
he was annoyed with you like maybe he's
just over you sorry yeah honestly it
could be not that he's over you but like
he is was looking forward to a break I
feel like anyone at this point in
quarantine we're on week seven if you've
been with one person the entire time
like you look forward to a break yeah
what'swhat's it count um so I wouldn't
get so discouraged and I don't think
that it's heat up that he doesn't care
about you at all I do think though that
in quarantine like it it's weird times
like I'm hearing crazy stories about
people who are meeting on hinge and then
their quarantine inks together for a
week at their parents house like just
it's it's crazy and it makes you like
want to be romantic and come up oh my
god I have a private jet come on the jet
come to the farm like it's crazy it's
quarantine but it's also still real life
so I understand it he's a bit more of a
pragmatist about this but it's a bummer
because you've probably just been living
this like you fantasy of like you and
your man and it's just the two of you
against the world and now he's like
going to live this large life and if you
can't even get a ride on the few J like
it's a bummer I don't think it doesn't
mean that he does I don't think it means
that he doesn't care about you I don't
think the relationship is as serious as
you might want it to be because if he
wanted that same serious relationship he
would have he would have loved to take
this opportunity to invite you like um
cuz you know you'll never have this
amount of time together with his family
again or maybe his family he's just
super old-school and they're we never
let him like invite a girl that he's
been dating for six months to come and
live with them for a few weeks so it's
not so much about you it is about the
circumstances I don't think that he's
over you because of quarantine I think
he was like looking forward to this
break you know switching it up being
with different people but it is a bummer
like cuz it seems like he's having a
blast and you're not ya know I'm really
sorry to be harsh but the vibe that I'm
getting it's just that he's over you and
like quarantine was enough for him to
just you learn a lot about someone and
not everyone's meant to be together and
like if I'm just like I just look at
things as to how I would perceive it if
it were happening to me and I'm like so
self-conscious and I've such a fear of
rejection so I'm like oh you don't to be
with me like you obviously don't like me
oh well if you were me and I booze with
someone for a whole month that I've only
been dating for six months I would be so
excited to be rid of them I would rather
be alone in my small apartment and with
them in their whole family that I've
never met for a few weeks in like a
state I've never been to that one
percent but Montana does sound lovely
this time of year yeah it does and I've
actually I've been to Montana it's quite
beautiful those are all of our deer
toasters and that's our show anything
else you want to say Jax before I let
everyone go no I think that's all she
wrote I've got lots of TV to catch up on
maybe start a book Oh redheads Book Club
episode of shopping first Thursday of
the May so I haven't started the book
yet it's in five years by Rebecca Searle
and if you're interested in joining a
book club now is the time you have so
much time to read the book and then we
will drop the episode discussing it I'm
so excited thank you guys so much for
listening to the morning toast the
millennium morning show where we go by
Monday through Friday 10:30 a.m. Eastern
Time on YouTube so if you're watching us
on YouTube please subscribe and give
this video a thumbs up we're also
available as a podcast anywhere podcast
can be found so that's about if I iTunes
stitcher public radio buy our videocast
box all the places wherever you listen
to podcast find us the morning show
sling a five-star view about a beautiful
something smart we are we love you guys
very much we'll see you tomorrow bye